[Music]
they traveled more than a thousand
kilometers to find jobs
in one of the most dangerous places to
live and work
in nigeria they ended up in the hands of
boko haram
bound and then slaughtered
43 victims laid to rest in the cemetery
i've never seen anything like this in my
life you can see 43 dead bodies here up
to now there are some bodies that are
yet to be recovered from the bush
indeed it is a frightening situation a
search
is being carried out for dozens of
others who are missing
but most are presumed dead sick
survivors are being treated in hospital
for serious injuries the state governor
is turning to local vigilante groups for
help
we shall ensure more recruitment of
civilian jtf and more hunters
so that our people will take the fight
to all the nooks and crannies of this
area
the farm workers were contracted to
harvest crops some 25 kilometers away
from the city of maiduguri
the manner that were killed suggests the
attackers who are careful
not to attract attention last month the
armed group
killed 22 farmers in two separate
attacks outside the regional capital
category
the president has issued a statement
condemning the recent attack
but after a decade of such raids by boko
haram and the ongoing ethnic violence
kidnappings and robberies many nigerians
say the government
is not doing enough to protect them the
united nations resident representative
issued a statement condemning the attack
saying many women
had also been abducted an estimated 36
000 nigerians have been killed by boko
haram over the past 11 years
and more than two and a half million
have been displaced security forces are
obviously losing this war
and this particular attack and others we
have seen in the last eight months or so
where attacks were attached that are the
product of the security forces on
strategy
uh last year which is 2019 was the
deadliest year for security forces in
nigeria since the boko haram was started
for many years the nigerian government
had been claiming victory over boko
haram
but the armed group continues to attack
both civilian and military targets
with devastating results this latest is
one of the worst
since the start of the boko haram
insurgency that was launched twelve
years ago
and has now spread to neighboring child
cameroon
and niger where thousands of civilians
and security personnel
have been killed ahmed iris jazeera
abuja